[Musik]
jubel bei sachsens cdu nach ersten
hochrechnungen bleibt sie vorn auf platz
zwei eine starke fdp in brandenburg
behauptet die spd die spitze knapp
dahinter die alt
gedenken wir an den deutschen angriff
auf polen vor 80 jahren den beginn des
zweiten weltkriegs bundespräsident
steinmeier bittet polen um vergebung und
zweimal gold bei ruder-wm deutschland
achter und oliver zeidler im einer sind
ihrer konkurrenz eine bootsspitze voraus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen zu diesem mit
spannung erwarteten wahlsonntag sport
gibt es auch mit kristin otto gab
reichlich davon genannt die
ministerpräsidenten in sachsen und
brandenburg können für den moment
aufatmen sowohl die cdu von michael
kretschmer in dresden als auch die spd
von dietmar woidke in potsdam bleiben
wohl stärkste kraft allerdings müssen
beide volksparteien kräftig federn
lassen und sich neue regierungspartner
suchen
großer gewinner ist die afc und matthias
fornoff hat in unserem wald studio in
dresden die neuesten zahlen matthias
guten abend aus dresden punkt 19 uhr
haben wir eine frische hochrechnung
zunächst mal für sachsen und die schauen
bei uns hier an
demnach kommt die cdu auf 33,1 prozent
die linke auf 10,3 die spd auf 7,4 die
afg auf 28,1 die grünen auf 8,3 und die
fdp wäre nicht drin mit 4,5 die freien
wähler bei 3% wir schauen noch kurz auf
diesen beiden hier unten das sind die
gewinne und verluste
da sehen wir fast alle verlieren etwas
die afd gewinnt 18 prozentpunkte dazu
die grünen noch etwas die freien wähler
und die fdp aber der große gewinner hier
eindeutig die afg und wir schauen mal
auf die sitzverteilung die absolute
mehrheit liegt bei 61 die cdu kommt auf
46 die linke auf 14 sitze die spd auf 10
die afg auf 39 und das müssen wir kurz
erklären das sind nämlich neun sitze
mehr als ihr kandidaten auf der liste
zugestanden worden sind sie hat also
mehr sitze gewonnen als kandidaten auf
der liste sind das
landesverfassungsgericht hatte das wegen
formfehlern so entschieden dass eine
besonderheit die grünen 11 sitze und
jetzt schauen wir was das heißt für das
regieren in sachsen welche koalitionen
haben eine mehrheit wir sehen hier den
senkrechten strich bei 61 sitzen da muss
man drüber
cdu und spd die bisher regieren kommen
auf 56 verfehlen das recht deutlich mit
den grünen zusammen sind es 67 das würde
reichen schwarz grün reicht nicht cdu
und fdp wir hier nicht aus weil es immer
ausgeschlossen wo
jetzt schauen wir auf die hochrechnung
für brandenburg und da sehen wir die spd
bei 26,6 die cdu bei 15,4 die linke bei
10,4 die afg auch hier mit deutlichem
gewinn verdoppeltes ergebnis 24,5 die
grünen 9,5 verbessert freie wähler fünf
prozent so rund um die fünf prozent
grenze eben und die fdp wäre nicht drin
mit 4,4 und wir gehen jetzt direkt auf
die frage wer denn mit diesem ergebnis
regieren könnte spd und linke die bisher
in potsdam regieren kommen noch 36 sitze
wir sehen zwar die absolute mehrheit
liegt bei 45 das reicht nicht
spd linke mit grünen das würde
haarscharf reichen mit exakt 45 sitzen
spd cdu und grüne bei 50 das würde
reichen an diesem abend in brandenburg
kann eben auch vieles noch daran hängen
ob die freien wähler am ende rein kommen
oder nicht die wahlbeteiligung an
letzter satz dazu ist in beiden ländern
von unter 50 prozent deutlich gestiegen
auf 60 prozent und 65 prozent in sachsen
spannende situation in sachsen und
brandenburg danke matthias und wir hören
nach was die spitzenkandidaten in
sachsen dazu zu sagen haben
bettina schausten hat die runde in
dresden um sich versammelt bettina 1 ist
wohl klar die regierungsbildung dürfte
schwierig werden
ja das können wir gleich fragen michael
kretschmer der wahlsieger hier in
sachsen cdu ministerpräsident herr
kretschmer sie am rang eins für die cdu
in sachsen behauptet gleichwohl sind die
verhältnisse jetzt durchaus schwieriger
zur regierungsbildung vielleicht mit den
grünen oder doch minderheitsregierung
das will ich noch mal fragen bleibt es
denn dabei dass sie nicht nur eine
koalition mit der fdp sondern auch jede
zusammenarbeit tolerierung ausstellern
das habe ich mehrmals gesagt ich möchte
dass dieses land eine stabile regierung
bekommt und ich sehe in diesem landtag
sehr sehr viele positive kräfte mit
denen man auch nach vorn arbeiten kann
die gute ideen für dieses land haben und
erwachsene menschen müssen in der lage
sein sich dann zu einigen und ich bin
willens dazu und die cdu auch herr gap
hat sie haben mir im wahlkampf auf die
frage warum die afg die linke als
protestpartei im osten abgelöst hat
geantwortet weil die linke es versäumt
hat
ostdeutschland in den fokus ihrer
politik zu stellen ist das der grund für
ihre massiven verluste ich kann die
frage nicht abschließend beantworten
heute abend ich glaube tatsächlich dass
wir eine herbe niederlage eingefahren
haben
das ist eine katastrophe was heute abend
mindestens das ergebnis für die linke
betrifft auch für mich persönlich ist
das eine herbe niederlage
an was es gelegen hat das kann ich ihnen
nicht beantworten und muss man
analysieren die nächsten tage und wochen
und dann muss man die ihre notwendigen
schlussfolgern daraus ziehen es ist
jetzt nicht alle abenteurer ende abend
wir werden wiederkommen und stark genug
dann auch sein und genug opposition
machen hier im sächsischen landtag
martin dulig ist hier spd
wirtschaftsminister des landes obwohl
sie auch persönlich gute werte verweisen
können haben sie zwischen sieben und
acht prozent eingefahren da werden sie
enttäuscht sein woran lag's ist das
ergebnis dieses schlechte ergebnis
hausgemacht oder lag's daran dass sie so
gar keinen rückenwind aus berlin
bekommen haben ja das ist da spd jetzt
das nicht gut geht das wissen wir alle
und das haben wir auch jetzt auf unserem
rücken mit ausgebadet aber man merkt
natürlich beiden landtagswahlen dass
hier eher die frage war wer von den
regierenden parteien gestärkt wird gegen
eine gegen einer starken der afg und
dementsprechend haben in brandenburg
meine kolleginnen kollegen der spd und
hier in sachsen im die cdu sozusagen das
rennen gemacht da gratuliert auch
michael kretschmer persönlich dazu aber
das klappe waren entscheidende gründe
warum das wahlergebnis in sachsen so ist
wie es ist
jetzt müssen wir damit umgehen man darf
auch mal traurig sein kurz aber ich habe
zuvor sich zwar kampf gemacht und das
gilt auch für die nächsten tage und
bleiben in der regierung an der seite
von kretzschmar vielleicht dann mit den
grünen
es ist also eine gute nachricht dass wir
politisch stabile verhältnisse auch in
zukunft haben können natürlich muss man
darüber reden unter welchen bedingungen
das geht aber es ist möglich und das
doch die gute nachricht des tages
erobern sie haben das ergebnis ihrer
partei fast verdreifachen können ein
riesenerfolg für die afd
das ziel stärkste partei zu werden und
sie selbst ministerpräsident zu werden
haben sie nicht erreichte auch will
keine partei im landtag mit ihnen
koalieren
welche rolle wird die afg im zukünftigen
landtag einnehmen und was wird sie tun
um die polarisierung des landes zu
überwinden
also als erstes möchte ich mich wirklich
ganz deutlich bei den sächsischen
wählern bedanken dieses ergebnis ist
fantastisch vor allen dingen wenn man
sieht wie die wahlbeteiligung gewachsen
ist heißt das ja auch das unheimlich
viele männer
neu zur hälfte als wähler gefunden haben
und vor dem hintergrund einer massiven
kampagne gegen uns die ja von medien von
gewerkschaften von kirchen getragen
wurde ist dieses ergebnis umso besser
aber ihr geht es nicht weiter wir werden
wir werden wie schon bisher eine
konstruktive oppositionsarbeit machen
viele unserer anträge in dem in der
letzten legislatur wurden am ende obwohl
sie erst mal abgelehnt wurden später von
der regierung umgesetzt das ist da kann
man traurig sein darüber aber wir können
auch sagen das ist ein ergebnis wie
oppositionsarbeit funktionieren soll
und wenn dann noch große positionen
werden wir das natürlich noch intensiver
machen und ob eine regierung aus sports
rot grün am ende wirklich stabile
verhältnisse für sachsen bringt da mache
ich erst mal ein großes fragezeichen
dran hat ja meist bei uns die
grünen-spitzenkandidatin jahrfeier
sachsen ist ergrünt wenn auch längst
nicht so wie sie sich das vielleicht
erhofft und erwünscht hatten aber sie
stehen jetzt bereit für ein bündnis was
immer kenia koalition heißt also mit cdu
und spd sind sie gewählt vor fünf jahren
wurde sondiert und sie haben sich
dagegen entschieden
zunächst einmal haben wir grünen das
historisch beste ergebnis was wir grünen
in diesem bundesland je erreicht haben
und wir haben vor allem im auftrag von
den bürgerinnen und bürgern hiervon
bekomme ich glaub es würden noch ein
sehr sehr langer wahlabend werden wir
kämpfen hier auch in sachsen um
direktmandate und dann wird sich
entscheiden welche mehrheiten es in
diesem land gibt und ja klar wir haben
gesagt wir wollen verantwortung
übernehmen was aber auch ganz klar ist
es kann kein weiter so geben mit cdu und
spd und wir grün dann als anhängsel die
ein bisschen umweltpolitik machen
sondern das muss ich ganz klar was
ändern da hören wir schon da beginnen
die koalitionsverhandlungen schon wir
dürfen dankeschön sagen in die runde und
geben aus dresden zurück nach mainz und
ich danke auch an die ganze runde
wir machen weiter in brandenburg dort
hat die spd den zweikampf mit der afg
offenbar ganz knapp für sich entschieden
muss sich jetzt aber neue
regierungspartner suchen
bettina wagen ist in potsdam mit den
spitzenkandidaten bettina du bist dran
bei mir ist ministerpräsident dietmar
woidke gerade nochmal stärkste fraktion
geworden
mit wem wollen sie jetzt regieren also
jungs
von vornherein klar gemacht dass wir mit
allen parteien im landtag vertreten sind
sondieren werden außerdem auf dem und
werden versuchen erstmal gemeinsame
projekte zu finden also die wahlprogramm
auch nebeneinander zu legen und dann zu
gucken wie kann man das land
voranbringen aber am ende wird es ganz
entscheidend sein dass es eine stabile
regierung gibt und wir haben in
brandenburg nur drei monate zeit
und deswegen kommt es darauf an erst
geschwindigkeit aber auch die nötige
qualität zu haben um die stabilität
herzustellen für das land für die
kommenden fünf jahre die die menschen
von uns erwarten denn eine stabile
regierung ist die grundlage dafür dass
das land auch weiter vorankommt es
entstehen bei der letzten mal waren sie
zweitstärkste kraft deswegen kommen sie
auch jetzt als zweites dran aber
momentan sind sie weit davon entfernt
sie haben im vorfeld mal gesagt sie sind
durchaus offen für die grünen sie sind
offen für jeden machtwechsel
aber sehen sie für sich noch eine option
im machtwechsel herbeizuführen
zu aller erst heute ist er die regierung
abgewählt wurden in brandenburg rot rot
nach zehn jahren und jetzt geht es darum
ob demokraten gemeinsam brücken bauen
können
in diesem land zu themen brücken bauen
können zwischen menschen brücken bauen
können und wir haben immer gesagt wir
wollen das dann verändern mitgestalten
voranbringen und deswegen auch gerne
bereit dazu aber einladen wird in der
demokratie dann derjenige der die wahl
gewonnen hat aber wir haben ganz klar
gesagt wir wollen unsere ideen
einbringen kann und besser machen
bildungspolitik ist unser hauptthema in
den nächsten fünf jahren daran werden
auch arbeiten
bei mir ist kathrin dannenberg die linke
hat deutlich verloren haben sie sich zu
spät um die menschen gekümmert
das ergebnis ist bitter für uns wir
werden jetzt natürlich in uns gehen
müssen und überlegen was wir zukünftig
besser machen natürlich also es ist hat
sich so gestaltet dass wir anscheinend
zu spät
ja mit den menschen geredet haben wir
haben das ja auch zu unserem
wahlkampfthema gemacht es geht ums ganze
haben mir gesagt es geht
gegen die spaltung dieser gesellschaft
wir stehen weiterhin und das ist ein
klarer auftrag unserer wählerinnen und
wähler weiter für soziale gerechtigkeit
zu kämpfen für gute löhne für faire
mieten aber auch natürlich und das steht
ganz vorn für ein tolerantes und
weltoffenes brandenburg andreas kalbitz
sie haben mit ihrer afd heftige kritik
im vorfeld provoziert sie haben willy
brandt für sich verändert mit einem
zitat auch wände zitate wie wollen sie
jetzt in der opposition die bände
vollenden wie sie es nennen also erstmal
freue mich über das sehr gute ergebnis
sind hervorragendes ergebnis werden
unsere prozente mehr als verdoppelt das
war auch ein produkt harter arbeit via
dass in sachsen schon angesprochen hat
gegen einen zusammenschluss aus parteien
aus gewerkschaften aus kirchen
jetzt geht es darum diese
oppositionsarbeit festzuschreiben dass
zu verfestigen
eines ist aber auch klar und das ist als
signal wichtig sowohl in brandenburg als
auch in sachsen die afd ist gekommen um
zu bleiben wer am anfang noch dachte das
sei ein protest phänomen zieht sich
jetzt eines besseren belehrt und es wird
dann an den anderen parteien seien mal
ihr demokratieverständnis zu überprüfen
wir waren wirklich versucht dann ein
viertel der wähler konsequent
auszugrenzen wir sind da relativ offen
auch sagt politisch orientiert und der
rest wird sich erst zeigen
frau nonnemacher die grünen haben
zugelegt vielleicht auch weniger als
gedacht für rot-rot wird es nicht
reichen schließen sich jetzt dieser
geschwächten regierung an
also wir haben deutlich dazugewonnen
dass es für uns ein ganz hervorragendes
ergebnis wir haben als wahlziel
ausgegeben das wir gerne zweistellig
werden wollen das scheint mir heute
abend noch die frage ob wir dieses
wahlziel erreichen können das kann
durchaus noch passieren
aber ja wir haben die hervorragenden
umfrage ergebnisse der letzten wochen
jetzt auf den letzten metern nicht eins
zu eins in wählerinnen stimmen umsetzen
können ich denke das ist der starken
polarisierung der letzten tage
geschuldet wird die afg die stärkste
kraft oder schafft die spd es die
stärkste kraft zu werden meint
glückwunsch an herrn dr woidke dass die
spd diesen platz belegt dass es mir das
eindeutig libre signal in diesem land ja
wir werden schauen was die wählerinnen
und wähler rinnen uns dafür einen
auftrag gegeben habe und wir sind bereit
verantwortung zu übernehmen
aber es kommt natürlich auf die inhalte
an also unsere inhalte müssen in
einer neuen regierung selbstverständlich
berücksichtigung finden nur eine
laufzeitverlängerung für rot-rot wird es
mit uns nicht geben
bitter wieder von den freien wählern 6%
für liste 6 lautet ihr slogan haben sie
den protest eingesammelt der nicht zur
fdp
ich glaube wir unsere inhalte kennt
stellt solche fragen nicht wir stehen
für eine sachorientierte arbeit wir
stehen für stärkung des ländlichen raum
ist rückzahlung ab was halt dann
schließe beiträge kein weiteres geld für
den br dass eine sachorientierte arbeit
der politischen mitte so haben die
letzten jahre gehandhabt und so wird es
auch weiter gehen
noch eine letzte frage an den
ministerpräsidenten teilen bitte um
einer kurzen antwort wird die
regierungsbildung mit drei parteien
jetzt schwierig wird es besonders
schwierig werden ich war in so einer
regierung noch nie dabei deswegen
erwarte ich dass er schon ein bisschen
schwieriger wird als mein partner hat am
tisch sitzen vor fünf jahren hatten noch
dazu ein partner mit dem wir schon fünf
jahre gearbeitet hatten aber ich glaube
auch da kann das neue impulse geben für
das land und ich glaube dass wir alle
die verantwortung tragen und die mensch
von uns erwarten dass wir schnell eine
stabile regierung schaffen und dann
dieses land weiter voranbringen und ich
sehe die partner
einige sind hier heute am tisch die
stehen bereit wir werden intensiv
sondieren und eine stabile regierung
haben ja und unter großer anteilnahme
des publikums draußen vor dem landtag
geben wir jetzt wieder zurück das ist
der vorteil eines transparenten wahl
studios vielen dank nach potsdam
die verluste der volksparteien in den
beiden ostdeutschen bundesländern
dürften auch die große koalition in
berlin belasten gerade die spd bei der
heute die bewerbungsfrist der kandidaten
für den parteivorsitz ab läuft hier die
reaktionen zu den landtagswahlen aus der
hauptstadt diese ergebnisse von heute
abend
diese gemischten gefühle über freude und
auch enttäuschung sie sind für uns
herausforderung und ansporn zugleich die
vor uns liegenden aufgaben auch in
deutschland auch in der bundespolitik
mit voller entschlossenheit anzugehen
es gibt viele menschen die in
brandenburg und auch in sachsen ganz
klar die demokratischen parteien gewählt
haben um ein zeichen gegen die afg zu
setzen
wir haben aber
auch viele menschen die ganz klar fdp
gewählt haben um vor allem auch protest
auszudrücken
ich bin nicht nur zufrieden ich bin
hochzufrieden man sieht er wäre hier der
wahlsieger ist wir haben uns für
zweieinhalbfache gegenüber dem
landtagswahlergebnis 14 in sachsen
wir haben uns mehr als verdoppelt wie es
aussieht in brandenburg ich glaube viel
besser kann es nicht laufen wir hatten
zwischendurch das stimmt natürlich eine
bessere umfragen auf dem wahlkampf in
den wahlkampf lauf und denke ich das ist
offensichtlich dass sowohl in
brandenburg zur spd wie in sachsen zur
cdu auch grüne wähler hingegangen sind
um zu verhindern dass die afg stärkste
kraft wird die linken standen immer für
einen protest der voller achtung
gegenüber den menschen und gegenüber der
demokratie war und sehen ob ich haben
sich schon einige jetzt dafür
entschieden auf eine antwort vom zu
setzen das ist aber sache der protest
für den die fdp steht ist ein protest
voller verachtung gegenüber menschen
leben und voller verachtung gegenüber
der demokratie wir sind nicht bis in die
parlamente gekommen der anlauf zurück in
die parlamente in potsdam und dresden
ist ganz offensichtlich länger ich war
optimistisch auch durch die gut
besuchten veranstaltungen die gute
stimmung im land aber die zahlen heute
zeigen sehr viele werden aus taktischen
gründen trotz sympathie für die fdp
anders gewählt haben
soweit die reaktionen aus der hauptstadt
direkt im anschluss an diese sendung
geht es zurück ins wahlstudio nach
dresden und die aktuellen ergebnisse und
entwicklungen im laufe des abends können
sie auch jederzeit bei uns im netz
nachlesen im liveticker auf heute.de der
erste september wird immer ein
besonderer jahrestag seien der beginn
des zweiten weltkriegs vor 80 jahren
griff deutschland polen an
heute die mahnung vom bundespräsidenten
nie wieder dürfen deutsche rufen
deutschland deutschland über alles
das sagte frank walter steinmeier auf
der zentralen gedenkveranstaltung in
warschau zu der die polnische regierung
auch die bundeskanzlerin eingeladen
hatte
am ersten september 1939 bombardierten
deutsche flieger als erstes die
polnische kleinstadt wielun natalie
steger berichtet
schon der zeitpunkt des gedenkens ist
eine starke geste früher morgen so wie
damals in lyon als der krieg begann um 4
uhr 40 fielen die ersten deutschen
bomben auf polen bundespräsident
steinmeier und polens staatspräsident du
da ein tag im zeichen der versöhnung
welcher deutsche wollte auf jeden
schauen auf warschau oder palmieri auf
auschwitz oder andere orte der shoah
ohne scham zu empfinden
seine wichtigsten worte des tages sag
ihr auch auf polnisch das bitten um
vergebung branche ob spanier für mich
ist es am wichtigsten dass sie hier sind
der bundespräsident das ist eine form
der moralischen wieder gutmachen
vor 80 jahren greifen sturz kampfbomber
die noch schlafende stadt köthen 1200
einwohner das erste deutsche
kriegsverbrechen in der stadt sind keine
polnischen soldaten nur zivilisten
steinmeier trifft sich in wien auch mit
überlebenden
ich werde ihm vergeben aber für mich und
meine generation ist es schwer
wir haben damals zu viel im leben
verloren in warschau das zentrale
gedenken vertreter der eu und nato
staaten hat polen eingeladen russland
nicht auch hier zeit zeugen steinmeier
bittet erneut um vergebung
wir vergessen die bunten die deutsche
polen zugefügt haben
die botschaft des tages ein nie wieder
und so läuten sie beide die glocke zum
gedächtnis und so macht
unsere polen korrespondent in natalie
steger hat die wichtigsten momente von
heute auch in einem ausführlichen film
zusammengefasst gedenkfeiern zum
ausbruch des zweiten weltkriegs zu sehen
heute nacht um 00 50 oder jederzeit in
der mediathek und auch in deutschland
wurde an den jahrestag des deutschen
angriffs auf polen erinnert in berlin
werben bundestagspräsident schäuble und
seine polnische amtskollegin vitek für
ein zentrales denkmal für die polnischen
weltkriegs opfer
die initiative wird auch von mehr als
200 bundestagsabgeordneten unterstützt
nach hongkong
dort spitzt sich die lage weiter zu
einen tag nach den schweren
ausschreitungen haben tausende
demonstranten den flughafen belagert
trotz eines zutrittsverbot sie
blockierten die größte zufahrtsstraße
zum terminal und setzten barrikaden in
brand sicherheitskräfte verriegelten die
zugänge die proteste richten sich gegen
polizeigewalt aber auch gegen chinas
kommunistische führung an der grenze
zwischen israel und dem libanon hat es
heftige schusswechsel gegeben nach
angaben des israelischen militärs seien
mehrere panzer abwehr raketen aus dem
libanon im norden des landes
eingeschlagen
zu dem angriff bekannte sich die
radikal-islamische hisbollah-miliz
israel reagierte mit gegenangriffen ein
harter brax it ist nach einschätzung von
eu chefunterhändler barnier kaum noch zu
vermeiden
der britische premierminister johnson
halte am austrittstermin ende oktober
fest deshalb komme für großbritannien
nun der moment der wahrheit schreibt
barnier in einem gastbeitrag für eine
britische zeitung nach verhandlungen des
brh exit vertrags mit london schließt er
weiter aus bei einer verkehrskontrolle
im us-bundesstaat texas hat ein mann
mindestens sieben menschen erschossen
und 20 personen wurden verletzt
der angriff hatte laut polizei bei einer
normalen kontrolle begonnen damit der 30
jährige eröffnete plötzlich und wahllos
das feuer dann fuhr er weiter und
kaperte einen lieferwagen auf einem
parkplatz wurde er von der
polizei erschossen das motiv ist unklar
der wirbelsturm dorian ist zu einem
hurrikan der gefährlichsten kategorie
hochgestuft worden er wird heute die
bahamas treffen
ausläufer haben die nördlichen inseln
schon erreicht
befürchtet wird dass dorian
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 320
stundenkilometern sechs meter hohe
wellen und sinnflutartigen regen bringt
anfang der woche trifft er dann wohl
möglicherweise abgeschwächt auf die
us-küste noch eine nachricht aus
deutschland bei einem open konnte open
air konzert in essen sind gestern abend
28 menschen verletzt worden zwei davon
schwer
sie schweben aber nicht mehr in
lebensgefahr während eines schweren
gewitters waren am baldeneysee
bühnenteile ins publikum gestürzt
das konzert der rapper materie und
kasper wurde abgebrochen und 20.000
besucher mussten das gelände verlassen
und damit sind wir beim höchstleistungen
im sport christel genau gibt es los mit
zweimal gold für die deutschen ruderer
zum abschluss der weltmeisterschaften in
linz nach dem triumph des
deutschland-achters gewann auch oliver
zeidler im einer
der erste deutsche seit dem wm-sieg von
marcel hacker vor 17 jahren ein großer
ein glücklicher ein goldener tag für den
deutschen ruderverband oliver zeit lässt
sich im einer eine zentimeter
entscheidung vor drei jahren war er noch
schlimmer und jetzt oder könig unfassbar
tränen die augen weil ich wirklich vor
schafft gestützt habe und das war hat er
hat heute einfach alles gepasst
wie passt da doch alles beim
deutschland- achter der dritte wm-titel
in folge für die crew um schlagmann
hannes butschek nach vielen
enttäuschungen ein glänzender abschluss
der oder werden
erste saison erfolg für ferrari
gleichzeitig die premiere ganz oben auf
dem formel einzige des für charlie
claire mit trauerflor und den gedanken
an seinen gestern verunglückten freund
antoine hubert entschied der 21 jährige
den großen preis von belgien für sich
vor dem mercedes piloten lewis hamilton
und valtteri bottas für sebastian vettel
reichte es ins bad zu rang vier im
ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga hat bremen erstmalig
in dieser saison gepunktet werde
besiegte augsburg mit 3 zu 2 fehlstart
für die deutschen basketballer bei der
weltmeisterschaft in china
das team von bundestrainer henrik rödl
kam gegen mit favorit frankreich sehr
schwer ins spiel lag zwischenzeitlich
sogar 24 punkte zurück und verlor
letztlich trotz starker aufholjagd mit
74 zu 78 die deutschen
vielseitigkeitsreiter dominieren in
luhmühlen das geschehen bei ihrer
europameisterschaft sie holten den titel
mit der mannschaft sowie gold und silber
in der einzelwertung durch ingrid klimke
und michael jung und wir haben auch
radsport gesamtsiege der deutschlandtour
ist der belgier jaspers teilen der als
fünfter der letzten etappe von eisenach
nach erfurt das rote trikot verteidigte
tagessieger nach knapp 160 kilometern im
massenspurt der italiener so nicole
valley bester deutscher beste deutsche
in der gesamtwertung simon geschke und
emanuel buchmann auf platz zwölf und 13
alexander zverev hat zum ersten mal das
achtelfinale der us open in new york
erreicht durch einen viersatz erfolg
gegen den slowenen aljaz bedene nächster
gegner morgen diego schwarzmann aus
argentinien und hindernis
europameisterin gesa felicitas krause
markiert eine weitere bestmarke
drei tage nach ihrem deutschen rekord
über 3000 meter hindernis lief sie beim
istaf in berlin über die unüblichen 2000
meter hindernis
weltbestzeit in fünf minuten 52,8
sekunden eine wirklich tolle motivation
für die wm ende des monats und zuletzt
die deutschen volleyballerinnen stehen
im viertelfinale der em haben soeben
gegen slowenien glatt in drei sätzen
gewonnen
durchatmen wir gratulieren viel los
heute spurlos geht noch das wetter
morgen regnet es im südosten kräftig an
den alpen anhalten zum teil mit gewinne
gewittern
auch an der nordsee gibt es schauer
sonst aber bleibt es freundlich 13 bis
23 grad der dienstag wurden meist
freundlich und wieder wärmer so viel von
uns wir wünschen ihnen noch einen
spannenden abend und haben natürlich
weitere wahlanalysen für sie nachher um
10 vor 10 im heute journal mit claus
kleber